wait what's your name Mariah hi Vanessa
Vanessa nice to meet nice sweet all
right so the question for today and it
would be awesome if you can get as
specific as possible with the answer
okay is what are you doing tomorrow
well Holly after work play a game of
Call of Duty ghosts my wife and then
read to my daughter and son tomorrow we
have a conference of our attending and I
am going to be presenting a poster on
research that day and it is about this
disease called sarcoidosis I'm really
passionate about it I I feel like I had
loved the work that I do and it's gonna
be hopefully really engaging for others
as well hello foraging what is that it's
a laser cutter thing printer yeah and
what are you laid there cutting um I
think one make some cat earrings
oh well I'm retired so you know the
sky's the limit I don't know what I
would be doing maybe I'd be working in
my garden or going for a walk with
friends or I don't know I'm going to
going back to Japan by playing okay okay
what are you gonna do the first day you
get back to Japan I have to go to the
office my office okay what do you do
there yeah I have to check my patients
doctor medical doctor what are you guys
doing tomorrow well I'm doing homework
and going to the Botanical Garden and
then we're having dinner
friend Justin I'm helping my dad work on
a little beach house he bought with his
wife
meeting my friend Millia tomorrow me
tomorrow I'm
I'm gonna go sit at one of my favorite
coffee shops called Lestat's
and I'm gonna work on a drawing that
I've been working on I hope to meet new
artists there you know sometimes they
just happened to be there and I just
kind of want to like get in touch with
my creativity a little bit yeah you is
okay if you explain what the drawing is
about yeah of course
um well I've been inspired a lot by
religion and religious art and not being
religious myself I always find it
interesting to explore it from an
outside perspective so I'm working on
it's an old statue that I saw when I
traveled to Spain and I wanted to draw
the person holding a heart and then a
person on the ground kneeling with like
no heart and I'm not really sure what it
represents yet but it seemed to mean
something when I had the idea in the
first place so we'll see you we'll see
how it comes out tomorrow I have a
fitness session in the morning and in
the afternoon I paddle with my local
outrigger canoe club
what is tomorrow Tuesday I am waking up
for work firing into the city and
working 40 people I work at the
courthouse in San Francisco I am going
to volunteer at a physical therapy
office tomorrow to get hours for my
future job but I want to get
I'm gonna go to school to go to do my
luck no go home and play some of my
games maybe lots I like my friends the
party and that's me watching what's your
favorite part of school recess I am
taking my stepdaughters to the airport
taking my children to the school working
all day cooking dinner and going it Abed
what are you doing tomorrow I am gonna
go do all my work go to class
and then when I get home to play games
play outside and then go to bed and have
fun Bella if she even ain't even there
what's your favorite part of school my
favorite part is math I'm getting on a
plane back to Portland and then I'm
probably not gonna go to school and then
I have rehearsal after school what do
you I'm directing a one-act it's like a
short play with like four kids who are
younger than me oh yeah I am waking up
going to work and then probably grocery
shopping and all of that exciting stuff
that I didn't do this weekend because I
was on vacation what do you do for work
I'm the visual manager at Anthropologie
tomorrow I'll probably wake up eat and
sleep nothing in between nope I will be
going to work basically at 8 a.m. in the
morning and we'll be there to probably
about 6 p.m. to run night yeah what do
you want you want more specific sure
what do you do yeah yeah I enjoy my work
I'm a physician and I work in a company
that helps take care of County inmates
after work I go home and have dinner
with my family and often times we take a
walk with our dog down to the beach
tomorrow I'm gonna go school and try not
to fall asleep in class because it's
really it's like at the end of the years
it's really worrying on this lead
and afterwards I'm gonna go home and if
everything goes out we'll go to the gym
and play guitar afterwards probably
watching YouTube and go to a concert
rock concert so it's his birthday
tomorrow and it's a surprise for him but
we're gonna go on a mini adventure so
tomorrow's my birthday and have actually
no clue what I'm doing
aside from brunch with my daughter in
the boy after that I'm mad as out of my
control and we are celebrating his
birthday for the surprise and brunch
with my dad oh well we'll be here so
we'll do how detailed like we'll do a
breakfast first probably in our Airbnb
is that too detailed okay um after that
I have to kind of Google what to do next
but we were thinking of going to the
pier tomorrow check out the museum we're
tourists so we kind of have some plans
well if I wasn't a tourist I think I
would have no plans um
the Maritime Museum maybe and a nice
dinner somewhere that's about it if you
were where is home for you
I guess Hong Kong if you're in Hong Kong
and I asked you the same question what
Oh like if yeah there would be not
really an answer to that one and see how
it goes I probably have one meal plan
where I want to try that's pretty much
it it I'd say or friends that I was
gonna meet up with but if I was back
home I don't think I would have any
answer for you know work so I just
finished my study so I have no work
right now and back at home I don't have
a job there either so in limbo with no
real plans tomorrow I need to find an
apartment I'm moving currently I have a
roommate and I want to live by my own
but I live in LA and it's super
expensive so I'm struggling and finding
a one-bedroom apartment that is in my
budget probably I'll paint my nails
because and I think that's it that's
what I'm the door I'm studying for a
finalist since I get out of school I
have a final that's pretty tough coming
up Wednesday so I'm a little nervous
about that other than that maybe gonna
smoke a little weed before I start
studying I'm not gonna lie I'm a little
high right now but that's what the
beauty about San Diego California is you
could just be wild and free out here
tomorrow I am going to work ah let's see
it's Tuesday and my shift at work is
from 12 to 8 and the night
duties but I work as a hairstylist I
love what I do so I am really excited
about going to work and be specific as I
can with Monday let's see I feel like I
could go deep but I could be vague I
don't know let's see my days usually
consist of and we've talked about this a
lot before I really tried to get my head
on no matter what to make sure that I
start the day positively I find that
it's so important to especially in my
industry like it's a service industry so
every day for me when I go to work I
make sure not just to put on a face but
to really make sure that I go on with
the mindset of like I am there to serve
and I want to create a great experience
so from the time I get up I try to just
start positively whether I do a lot of
prayer and active like meditation like
throughout the day but in the beginning
I always try to just remind myself of
things to be grateful for and that
propels me into just a more positive day
obviously talking with that atom here
always is my person gets my day started
off positively as well
she said a fake name we had a plan in
case you ever caught on camera I didn't
use fake name yeah so I guess yeah I
could show that detail about my day and
interact with my family a bit and then
go to work and give my best to my
clients I come into my life and we
interacted what's up guys my name is
Mariah and I'm the owner of this channel
I'm also the person behind the camera
and I thought I'd take a minute to thank
all the subscribers I gained so far and
maybe ask new years to hit the subscribe
button if you liked this episode or if
you're fans with my channel in general
don't need a lot thank you